it is
january 3rd 2022
and it's time for another monthly update
video in which i'm going to talk about
what we've got coming up in january and
what you might have missed in december
just in case you want to put that on
your radar or go back to it i also did a
end of the year recap video so i'm not
going to talk about the whole year of
2021 you can go to that video which is
linked to below
if you would like to learn more about
that
so with no further ado three big things
coming up this month
my academic classes begin at least at
one of the places that i'm teaching
milwaukee institute of art and design
and so i'm gearing up for that and
shooting some new video content and
doing a lot of behind the scenes kind of
things
big thing number two those of you who
have been
patiently waiting for
new self-directed study videos to come
out i'm going to start doing those again
this month with one on augustine
and big thing number three if you don't
already know about stoicism today
selected writings volume three you
notice this is a proof copy that's why
it says not for resale
that came out in december and it's got a
lot of really great essays it's uh
co-edited by me and leah goldrick so you
might want to check that out if you have
any interest in stoicism you're going to
find a lot of really great
discussions of it how-to's even some
controversies
in there so let's talk now about
december and then we will jump into
january
so what did december hold well my
academic classes predictably enough all
came to a close there was a bit of drama
at the milwaukee institute of art and
design because the course management
system closed completely for not
technical college but available did
teach a class for carthage college and
that one came out okay as well grades
all got in
the students who are
taking incompletes are finishing them up
as we speak in december
we also for christmas did something
completely different and when i say we i
mean my wife andy and our cat sassy and
i we went up to green bay because at a
gala event we had bid on some packers
tickets for
christmas
and we actually won and so we drove up
to green bay on the 24th stayed in a
hotel got sassy situated
took her a little while to settle in the
first night she actually was up and down
and i had to attend her about every two
hours but uh all told it was pretty good
we went to the game packers won in a
very close game lots of fun drove down
the next day so that was our christmas
and we had a very low-key new year
as well
um i did you know my my usual events
my ask me anything session my public
hegel q a session
scott truly and i did a great session
for um
for classic metal class uh and i also
did the political theory and practice
discussion all of those are linked to
below if you want to see them
and we got two sessions of wisdom for
life in also two sessions of drive time
for river west in which i
um interviewed some some guests
including sam from southpaw podcast and
um
dan from the recombination area here in
milwaukee
as i mentioned you know i had classes
going on and and i also had a lot of
client work in december as well
including some new clients
um so i'm you know once again quite
blessed and that i do zero marketing or
uh promotion and clients find their way
to me for philosophical counseling
tutorials consulting
and various other things um video work
uh i got three half hour hegel videos
done not uh
not exactly what i wanted but at least i
got those done and
core concept videos i got to some
foucault videos that i'd been meaning to
do for a long time on the subject and
power
um finished out the
speculative fiction studies with uh
videos about leguins earthy books i i
know i had stuff on tahanu this last
month maybe also about the farthest
shore
there's also a video of an event that i
took part in with my friend and
collaborator harold covley
about pro races determining pro-racist
for the second brazilian epictetus
symposium hosted by aldo dinucci and
that was that was quite good
um
did some some interesting things using
the wombo ai art generator i did two
videos one using my full name gregory
bryant ignatius sadler and the other one
using the title of my
senior honors thesis isomorphic truth
self-referential statement groups and
you know they produced some interesting
art that i commented on
um we did worlds of speculative fiction
uh
but it wasn't a session instead it was
all about the voting for who's going to
be you know in the running this this
coming year
and then um
i did one sadler's honest reviews on
elliot rosenstocks the hyper state and
uh
it's uh
what is it the hyperstate and it's being
or something like that i don't have the
book right in front of me
podcast episodes i did a lot of podcast
episodes and these are for my my ethics
class on aristotle's nick mccann ethics
books eight and nine on friendship and
relationships in general and there's a
lot of cool stuff in there that i think
i'm going to go back to
then i did a sequence of three on peter
singer and his book the most good that
you can do and then finished it up with
some stuff from my existentialism class
on serving kierkegaard's the present age
so that was december and it kind of
limped to a halt
and i didn't get as much done as i would
have liked but you know i can say that
about just about every month
all right what do we have coming up in
january so the first thing i want to put
on your radar is two different dates
the 5th and the 19th those are
wednesdays from 4 to 6 pm central time
i will be on the air with drive time
from river west river west is our
community radio station here in
milwaukee but you can hear it anywhere
in the world by going to
riverwestradio.com link is below and you
can hear me and the co-host discussing
the news of the day and also
interviewing some very interesting
people
on the 8th at
noon i'll be hold holding my usual ama
that's ask me anything
session
also on the 8th at 2 pm for patreon
supporters i will be having my
philosophy
chat session
on the 12th at 5 p.m that's a wednesday
we'll have the public hegel q a
and discussion session
then on the 15th
at
noon classic metal class scott truly and
i have got a whole bunch of cool topics
lined up in advance that we're going to
be
talking about and uh delving into so
you're welcome to join us for that uh
people can ask questions make comments
and we respond to them
as we're going through it
on the 20th uh is uh
at noon is going to be the first live
reading of the month from my book this
is live reading number 18 from
reason fulfilled by revelation the 1930s
christian philosophy debates in france
we're still in the blondel section so
we'll be talking about that quite a bit
i'll read and then we discuss the
materials
on the 22nd at 12 p.m we have the first
worlds of speculative fiction
uh session of the
season of the year you could say and i
will be discussing
uh stevenson's anathem a book that i
have been plowing my way through it's
nearly a thousand pages for quite a
while and been putting off for a while
we're going to kick off
2022 with with that
and that takes place with a video
premiere at noon and then around 1 30
sometimes 1 40 depending how long the
video goes
i'll be having a live
session with people
do doing video conferencing talking
about it on the 23rd the next day at
noon we have our political theory and
practice discussion and you know given
all the um discussion that i've been
having in common some of it productive
some of it very unproductive about
foucault and power i think i'm going to
actually do something about
foucault and power relations
for that discussion
then on the 27th we've got two things
going on at noon we have our live
reading again from my book reason
fulfilled by revelation
and at 6 00 p.m milwaukee stoic
fellowship anybody's welcome because
it's a zoom session so if you've got an
interest in stoicism you can show up but
you do want to of course make sure you
do some of the cicero reading that we're
going to be discussing then finally on
the 29th at noon i will be
doing my self-directed study
in philosophy video on augustine we'll
do a video premiere which means that you
can watch it be one of the first people
to enjoy it and then
i'll be answering questions in live chat
about that
what else do we get going on that's a
busy month thank thank goodness we've
got like you know 31 days to it although
we've already burned through too
i got to get my classes up and running
because classes open up a day from to a
week from today
for my milwaukee institute of art and
design i've got a little bit more lead
time for the medieval philosophy class
that i'm teaching for carthage because
they have a j term which i'm not
teaching in so february i've got to be
ready for that medieval philosophy class
um i got a lot of client work to do you
know i've i'm a little bit behind on
correspondence there have been people
who have emailed me and i i have to get
back to them about you know
philosophical counseling or tutorials or
things like that
i'm also leading a reading group on
seneca that that meets four times
i think it may be past the deadline to
sign up for that it's been advertised on
my social media and in other places
um that's going to go on the the course
of this month not this monday but every
monday after this i'm hoping to do a lot
of writing this month as well
and of course i'm gonna be doing things
to promote stoicism today selected
writings volume
three uh we might have some interviews
with authors or some other cool stuff
going on maybe in the blog maybe in my
video channel maybe in other
venues
and then uh video work so
obviously half hour hegel we're now in
the revealed religion section i'd like
to keep making some headway there i'd
like to get my six videos for the month
done i'd like to get some sadler's
honest reviews done so far i've been
getting like one a month i'd like to
jack that up to about four a month so i
can start getting caught up on things
core concept videos i've got one more
foucault video to release and then i've
got to start shooting core concept
videos for my medieval philosophy class
so that means some cool new stuff on
augustine
and boethius i don't know if the
boethius will be released by the end of
the month
um but i'll certainly be shooting at
this this month i've also got to release
some of the le guin um
earth sea stuff that i i didn't get to
there's actually two whole books yet to
release so this month i will be
releasing videos on tales from earthsea
and then you know i'll do some more of
the wombo ai stuff there'll be videos
from the events and sessions that i'm
doing and i'll do some more sadler's
stories videos most likely i've got some
things to reminisce about that some of
you may be
interested in and we'll see what other
kinds of videos i want to shoot
podcast you know i'm still releasing
stuff on kierkegaard that i produced for
my existentialism class
i've got to do some stuff on nietzsche's
genealogy taking the videos that i
produced a while back and converting
them
to
podcast episodes taking out all the um
and things like that
and then you might see some augustine
podcast episodes come out as well
and that's pretty much taking us up to
the end so i hope that you're having a
good beginning of the new year i mean
nobody knows what's going to happen with
omicron and you know all the stuff that
you know
dislocations economically and things
like that that we're facing but
you know hopefully we can still have a
decent year
and learn a lot of stuff and engage in
some some good discussions and i hope to
see you at some of these online events
and you know maybe someday we'll be back
to
face-to-face events would be which would
be kind of nice and kind of cool
wouldn't it so
that's uh it from from me and uh
yeah happy new year to all of you
you